representative yoho put his finger in my
face he called me disgusting
he called me crazy he called me out of
my mind he called me dangerous
representative yoho called me and i
quote
a [ __ ]
[Music]
well i don't know who this
representative yoho is but uh i kind of
like him she's lip syncing to aoc
complaining and meanwhile we're supposed
to be i guess impressed by the vicious
sexist comments that she flashes up on
screen here there's like 12 comments
total she thinks she's a a badass girl
boss because she she withstood 12
mildly rude comments on the internet
lady do you want to see my
mention sometime you want to tussle i'll
tell you something
let's tussle so this is not gender
specific women don't have it any worse
on the internet than men do it's a
terrible place we're all rolling around
in the sewer on the internet it's gross
and dirty but we're here because we've
conditioned ourselves to find some sort
of sick satisfaction in it that's the
case for everyone so you're not a victim